as your cloud application scales you'll
eventually be faced with an
all-too-common problem how do I maintain
tight control over network resources but
not be a roadblock to team spinning up
the resources they need to do work in
this episode of cloud networking I show
you that you can have the best of both
worlds using shared views ease large
organizations with multiple cloud
projects value the ability to share
resources while maintaining logical
separations between groups or
departments and this makes complete
sense centrally Network admins are on
the hook to maintain sanity for the
overall network so sharing resources is
critically important but every team has
special needs meaning that it's a
constant churn for admins to have to set
up new projects access policies billing
quotas etc etc if your company is large
enough this can be a full-time job
that's why Google created shared VPC
which allows an organization to connect
resources from multiple projects to a
common VPC network so that they can
communicate with each other
securely and efficiently using internal
IPs from that network when you use
shared VPC you designate a project as a
host project and attach one or more
service projects to it
the VPC networks in the host projects
are called shared VPC networks with
shared VPC you can centrally manage the
creation of routes firewalls subnet IP
ranges VPN connections and more for the
entire organization and allow developers
to own billing quotas and I am
permissions and autonomously operate
their development projects for example
imagine you are the network admin at an
e-commerce company you have a single
externally facing web application server
that uses services like personalization
recommendation and analytics all
internally available but built by
different development teams you can have
a shared EPC network with a host project
and three service projects for
personalization recommendation and
analytics all on different subnets with
shared BPC the network and security
admin would set up the overall security
policies in the host project like
restricting which VMs can have public
IPS and access to the Internet by
setting up an organization policy
that disables external IP access for VMs
in this example the personalization
recommendation and analytic services
meanwhile each team would be able to
start spinning up VMs in their assigned
service project and decide more
fine-grain details like setting up
compute resources and VM still get the
same Network throughput caps and VM to
VM latency as when they're not on shared
networks let's dive into how to set up a
shared V PC at the organization level my
login Stephanie dot Wang currently has
org admin and shared V PC admin
privileges I can also assign the shared
DPC admin role in to somebody else in my
org switching over to my hosts project I
created a custom V PC called V PC one
and two subnets development and
production I also created two firewall
rules one to allow SSH to all instances
and network and one to allow ICMP
traffic between instances in these
subnets in the shared DPC page first
enable host project to be the host
project by clicking set up shared V PC
I'm going to select sharing individual
subnets this option allows you to share
specific subnets in the host project V
PC with your service project
then select the V PC one dev and prod
subnets let's attach two service
projects development and production make
sure the compute engine API has been
enabled in each service project before
attaching them here you can edit the
default permissions given to this
service project then click Save you can
now see host project is the shared V PC
host with two subnets and it has two
attached service projects this is also
where you can add additional host
project users and admins now I'm going
to log into my development project owner
account John who only has permission to
that project switching to the
development project create a new VM
and add a development tag then select
network shared with me from the host
project so that you can select the dev
subnet
once it's done creating copy the
internal IP of the instance since you'll
need it just in a second
next I'll switch to Mary's account who
is the owner of the production project
create a new VM in the production subnet
and add a production tag making sure to
change the zone to the one in the
production subnet region select the prod
subnet
when both VMS are done creating you can
see I can SSH into the prod instance and
ping the dev instances internal IP
address since I've created the right
firewall rules in the host project
shared VPC now you just want to make
sure that when configuring subnet IP
ranges in the same or different regions
you allow for sufficient IP space
between the subnets for future growth
plus GZ P lets you expand an existing
subnet without affecting any existing
VMS IP address and with zero downtime
how cool is that
shared V PC is a powerful feature that
makes GCP more flexible and manageable
for your organization yep that means you
might just have enough time to go
fishing on the weekend without a fire
drill ping interrupting that overhead
cast to learn more check out the
documentation link below and remember
optimizing your network means freeing up
your bandwidth
[Music]